I believe this organization should be
putting out somewhere in the ballpark of
two to five thousand pieces of content
across seven to ten channels on the
Internet a day to achieve the business
goals and ambitions that it has globally
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm super excited to be here it's it's
super flattering I especially as
somebody who loves to actually do public
speaking I've come to realize you know
this is so much more of a fun setting
for me mainly because of interaction so
I'm going to talk a little bit about a
couple things that I think will bring
the most value to the people in the room
and very honestly then I want to get
into as much Q&A as possible so so many
of the things that I believe are you
know going on and could impact an iconic
very large scale business like this is
widely available on YouTube or LinkedIn
and so I want to be a little bit more
specific or nuanced I think to set up
the framework because I'm gonna assume
most people don't know me or where I
stand on this I I believe that the
enormous technology advances that I'm
sure especially a company like this
understands and then the nuance is
underneath that infrastructure I think
that the collective in this room
including myself grossly underestimate
what it all actually means and because
it's so big it's so heavy it's so
transformative if you just think about
and kind of looking around the room here
a lot of people gonna be able to do this
if you truly spent a half a day with
yourself over you know a nice walk or a
bottle wine or however you like
decompress and think about what has
happened in technology advances just in
the last 20 years it gets quite scary
you know obviously you guys do a great
job physically showing that with mobile
devices and the progression but just the
whole nut everything I believe in the
which and my passion is how
communication basically dictates
everything we do right
I was born in this Soviet Union and so I
grew up in a was born in a place of
communism and then I was able to
immigrate to the US a place of
capitalism and and media in a very
different point of view and I think in a
lot of ways I was very in hindsight
taken aback by that or think about that
I constantly think about why when there
is a coup in a country do they go to the
newspaper and radio and television
station first before they even go to the
palace and it's because it's the
punchline the the thing that has the
control is communication and I think as
a matter of fact this argument this
debate this passion I've had for the
last 15 years has become much more
obvious to people as the political
landscape has changed across the globe
very much on the back of the modern
technology revolution when it comes to
communication and for me where I get
really excited as a businessperson is
when I'm met with the best products or
services that are not necessarily
winning the game that they're up to
completely and utterly on the back of
brand perception or execution of
communication at this moment and so I
couldn't imagine for example and not
knowing everybody's business units or
what you work on but every time I go to
a remarkable company inevitably there's
a high percentage of people in the room
that are working on something where they
are disproportionally the leader in
quality but the business results are not
matching that product or service
completely and utterly predicated on
either a you know being way too much of
a sales organization and not a marketing
brand organization or be not even
thinking about how the actual decision
maker is being affected to make a
decision and where can we reach them and
how and what have you and so for me
stumbling into the talent the natural
talent that that very nice bio what I
realized from having and this might
sound very interesting and it took me a
long time to realize it the reason I had
eight lemonade stands and I did the
reason I had eight lemonade stands as a
child which is
absurd and very unique is on a stage
like this actually five years ago I'm
giving the story I used to give my bio
more and I actually remembered for the
first time why was I doing that because
I was starting to get a little bit upset
with myself was I lazy and just one of
my friends to work but what I was
actually doing as a six year old kid as
a six year old child I was walking the
1980s and America was much more safe so
I was walking about in the neighborhood
and I was looking at the cars driving
and trying to figure out where to put my
lemonade stand sign on which tree or
which post of a sign and basically 37
years later right here right now I'm
still doing the same thing I've been
chasing the attention of human beings to
figure out where they're paying
attention and then I spend the rest of
my time trying to make a sign that's
gonna make them stop and buy my lemonade
and I very successfully did that for my
father's business on the back of modern
communication technology advances the
reason I was able to build a small wine
shop into a national player in no time
with no venture capital nope not even a
credit line working with my own small
capital three million dollar business
doing 10% gross profit to build that 260
million with no cash infusion in five
years
takes one move a remarkable ability to
make every penny work like a dollar in
acquiring customers how did I do that I
did that with email marketing and Google
AdWords because that was the enormous
arbitrage in the market from 1996 to
2001 an arbitrage and an understanding
of consumer behavior that my competitive
landscape did not understand that is
basically become the seed that allowed
me to later be an early investor in
facebook and twitter and tumblr because
I viewed them as the next paradigm
shifts and it's what makes me think
every night about voice-activated
devices with AI infrastructure behind
them because every consumer picks
convenience over everything
and we'll use those devices to make
decisions and then that becomes the new
toll booth two transactions
that's very consumer centric very much
what I think about when I think about a
company like this is how does that
translate to a b2b environment how does
that translate to the cliche things that
are at friction to my beliefs with an
engineer sales DNA driven organization
and it plays out in many ways but
ultimately what I think it plays out in
is I genuinely believe for this company
to take full advantage of 49,000 patents
to take full advantage of the speed in
which it's deployed to become a leader
in 5g and many other things that I'm
sure people are proud of or the
innovations that are happening
throughout the globe is a ironically to
become a media company itself and when I
say media I mean publishing I think over
the next decade or two you will see
companies like yourselves and your
competitors start to realize an
editor-in-chief will sit at the highest
levels in a company like this because
actually being publishing DNA is
imperative which is extremely difficult
for a company because if you're gonna be
a publisher you need to be a publisher
which is very different than being an
advertiser you know putting out content
that has no direct attribution to
something that you can measure in the
short term as a funnel to a sales center
to a transaction takes a level of
discipline especially if somebody's held
accountable for every 90 days or every
year but that will be the requirement
because a word that has been really
running through my head quite a bit over
the last couple of years as entitlement
mainly because I have exploded on
Instagram and I get 10,000 direct
messages a week from kids who are
wealthy affluent being totally taken
care of and they hate their parents for
creating entitlement and they don't know
how to get out of it but they're making
a lot of excuses that's a different
story but what I realize is that same
thing that a 19 year old whose parents
have paid for everything and
she or he is realizing wait a minute I'm
a zoo animal and I don't know how to
live in the wild I believe there's a
level of entitlement that is rampant
amongst the fortune 500 or biggest
companies in the world of thinking that
they're entitled to the business they
make audio dashes and points of view on
their competitive landscape they say
silly things like like make Raza's and
jokes about emerging competitors who
eventually become their biggest issues
and I've been thinking quite a bit about
that and I think it all leads to
actually a very interesting place which
is ultimately both high-net-worth
parents and executives of very big
companies unfortunately are not consumer
centric unfortunately play within their
b2b confines score on different metrics
than the actual end user that they're
supposed to be deploying for and so my
luck and that's what I'll call it AB DNA
of only ever being consumer centric has
led to the honor of sitting here and
talking to you and having people pay
attention and all the nice things that
have happened to me
and it's fun because there's nothing
more entrepreneurial or rogue or
disruptive than actually caring about
nothing in the middle but the end
consumer pandering to nothing not awards
not the press not the media not the b2b
environments not the conferences not the
people that are fancy just the end
consumer and building leverage there
which ultimately gives you leverage with
all the things that I just mentioned
that are in the middle and so for me
what that all all that pontificating
leads to the following Ericsson should
be putting out 250 pieces of LinkedIn
creative a day and it probably puts out
three nine seven and more importantly is
that picture video and written article
white paper is that been contextually
post produced for the understanding of
how LinkedIn algorithm works does it
understand
that the adjectives used in the copy
changed the difference of 37,000 people
seeing it versus 2.9 million people
seeing it is it a video that people
actually want to watch or was it a video
that somebody wanted to make because it
makes them feel good of what it looks
like
does it ladder up to the brand which is
a complete exercise of executives making
subjective calls
unfortunately so much of what big
companies do is an insular game of
politics pandering to reports that mean
nothing and a lot of other things that
ultimately become the demise of great
companies and it makes sense but it
doesn't have to be that way and the
place that I think is most practical to
actually make a hard change is marketing
and communication it's very hard to make
a quick change on your product it's more
difficult to change your culture it's
you know there's a lot of things that
are a challenge but not wasting your
media money on television commercials
that nobody watches banner ads and
nobody clicks and millions of other
executions that make no sense other than
to the [ __ ] reports that sit in the
middle to justify the bad behavior is
something I have an enormous passion for
especially when you have what I call
sawdust I'm super fascinated by sawdust
at some point in our world somebody
looked at people cutting wood and said
the stuff that's going on the ground is
something I can sell and I think about
that a lot
I also bottled water is the much more
interesting one I would probably pay an
uncomfortable amount of money to have
the right to in a VR exciting sit in the
room with whoever she or he was that
decided this was going to actually play
out selling something that was free to
the world because it as a marketer as
you can imagine that is a very
fascinating execution but that's
actually how I view a company like this
if you think about the sheer amount of
sawdust in the form of unbelievably
compelling tech stories that happened in
the halls globe
around the hundred thousand people that
are touching this place and you know one
man's point of view as an outsider the
sheer under rated nature of your
advances the end consumer complete point
of view on this company that is just not
fair to the level of what you're
actually achieving and even the b2b
industry that is actually doing business
with you they're even own perception of
what's happening here yes comes from
cliche the DNA of being a Nordic country
and the way you talk about yourself but
is that is in my opinion the obvious
excuse to just not being a modern
communications company and how you
address that and how you think about
deploying your stories your value
propositions your nuances across what I
believe is now the real call to arms no
different than this organization two
years ago taking a step back and saying
okay in a difficult European you can't
just fire everybody you know kind of
game how are we going to thread this
incredible business challenge of
updating our talent pool while becoming
pot committed to something like 5g
because maybe this last chapter hasn't
gone exactly how we wanted but by
winning the next thing we win and
honestly that is the most invigorating
thing of technology advances even if you
haven't done the last two kind of turns
as well as you wanted if you're the best
at the new turn you just leapfrog
everyone right and it's super
fascinating to me much like what you've
done operationally and organizationally
and have execute against some of your
core capabilities that's kind of how I
think about communication it's kind of
irrelevant how well you've done from
2011 to 2014 vironment s-- the next
decade is going to be one enormous game
of volume of output and whichever
biggest companies in the world to figure
that out first and can execute it will
disproportionally pick up market share
and what I mean by that for clarity was
I was probably being kind on how many
pieces of creative I think Ericsson
should be putting out on just LinkedIn a
day I genuinely believe what I'm about
to say as quickly as humanly possible
I believe this organization should be
putting out somewhere in the ballpark of
two to five thousand pieces of content
across seven to ten channels on the
internet a day to achieve the business
goals and ambitions that it has globally
as you can imagine that is a very
difficult DNA shift in a world where
people overanalyze every single thing on
if the color is blue enough or let's
spend for different meetings literally
debating a single adjective or let me
impose my political weight as the final
decision-maker
and just give some feedback that I
actually don't even know if I really
believe but I need to give it to justify
the fact that I even have a job and that
is literally how I say it and that's not
I'm not trying to be mean or as that's
just an observation and all of that is
the friction to putting out 5,000 pieces
of content a day so if I'm right which I
feel very confident about because it's
already happened
I tend a lot of what I've become is not
predicting the future it's over
communicating what's already happened
it's just that people aren't looking or
aren't incentivized to look in the same
place as I am looking so I think I think
Ericsson needs to be a competitor to NPR
and have 54 seperate podcasts in the
marketplace globally around the world
putting out a podcast a day I think
Ericsson needs to be today should not be
a day where everyone's so excited about
Mary Meeker
slide deck which is amazing and I am
excited for it but
the if you just think about the sheer IP
that sits within the for macro walls of
this organization to put out
extraordinary contemporary decks in fun
ways to consume across these platforms
to create leverage for our sales
organization to create revenue I just
think there's a there's a extraordinary
miss in the b2b environment and
somebody's going to take advantage of it
and I'd like I personally like to be
associated with it for my own long-term
being historically correct but it's
gonna be more fun to just just see it in
the wild because I think that's where
it's going so that's what I'm seeing and
I would love to I'd love to go into Q&A
and go a little more detailed with some
of that pontificating and so thank you
so much for having me so am I just gonna
hear it here repeat it for everybody
back home and the cameras great who's
got a question yes oh we do have a mic
awesome yes yes great thank you yes sell
that in because you're asking them to
help you produce content or sell them in
because you want them to amplify it or
sell them in because you want allocation
of more resources to higher
[Music]
so a macro media thing how do you do
that
you you do that in most organizations by
communicating in a way that may lead to
you getting fired I I think I think the
reason I answered that way is it's
actually the truth like if the people
that are actual practitioners of any
craft are not willing to be aggressive
with their convictions to communicate to
CFOs nothing will ever happen
the only other there's only two ways
I've ever seen big companies do the
right thing one a cheater leader who
mounted enough political clout to
actually get something done or to
massive pain at the macro level that has
required them to take a deep look at
themselves and change their behavior
that's it that's it that's it you know
you know you're gonna have to find who
can help you get it done to me to me the
ability that they or the internal and
external partners that create this
ability to communicate is oxygen you
know for me there are the amount of
things that I would be willing to give
up at this company if I was the CEO in
in return for the ability to put out
five thousand pieces across all
platforms being 500 on LinkedIn a day is
almost everything except the core
innovation definitely the bananas in the
in the hallway
I mean that and I mean it for a purpose
because as my profile has grown as my
results have spoken as many things have
happened you know I come from being a
businessman I'm not necessarily a comms
person by trade I've been an opera every
I'm quite proud that every day since
I've been a professional I've been the
CEO of a company that has grown
exponentially every day every single day
that I breathed from 22 to 43 I've been
at the helm as the CEO and CIO the way I
operate of two companies that have been
the fastest growing companies in their
sector I'm proud of that
what that also allows me to do is as the
last half decade of my career is evolved
I'm now sitting down with board members
CEOs CFOs activists investors and when I
look at a true P&L my ability to have a
logical financial or operational
conversation around the notion of you're
telling me of no more money to pour in
first 90 cents in the dollars that
you're spending on marketing and media
is going in the garbage you know you
have no money for social media but this
company is thrilled to buy a booth at a
[ __ ] conference that costs more than
the entire budget of your Linkedin media
spent let's just one more time and this
I don't I don't even know your P&L and I
know I'm right right now I know because
I know because it's a pattern
recognition I know that this company
will spend more money building out a
booth at some conference that matter 21
years ago then they will spend on
working media dollars properly deployed
on LinkedIn which is a which is the
global communications portal of the b2b
world the end like what what else needs
to be said to me that
in a world where I used to think I was
smart but the clapping and reactions in
this room overtime taught me I wasn't
smart I was just in a position where I
could tell the truth my question to this
reaction is so why what like how do we
fix that
who is your external media agency
partner who isn't incentivized to deploy
the dollars in your best interests
they're deploying it in their best
interests because they're inevitably a
holding company themselves that's
publicly traded and they're pushing
television and programmatic media spend
because that's where the margin is
that's the truth you know who's who's
gonna fix that obviously I heard earlier
today you have a new CMO and you know
it's her it's the CFO it's legacy you
know inevitably in companies like this
sometimes even at the family level or
the CEO level there's a relationship
with an agency that's 21 years which
inevitably means you're getting ripped
the [ __ ] off so you know these are the
things I'm thinking about yeah so I'm so
sorry that question is there's two
people posting how do we fix it
[Laughter]
two questions yes
great the question is how do you
actually practically deliver on this two
three four five thousand pieces of
content a day a week how does that
actually get done and the second
question is talking about a time I
failed and third please
I see how to completely out of my butt
and let me explain what I mean by that
I'd actually like it to be more I just
don't think you can get there and I
think about what my intuition is on how
much money you're wasting on marketing
and if that was deployed on the ambition
of making a lot of content that you
would get to those kind of numbers got
it
so whether listen I would dance if you
put out fifteen meaningful pieces of
LinkedIn content a day right you know I
would dance and meaningful and what I
mean by that is I have so much empathy
for internal teams trying to do it with
press releases everything and you
understand if if I was sitting and
having dinner with my mom right now and
she said hey son really like really
what's the punchline of why vaynermedia
and you are so right like what what has
been going on I would say mom it's our
post-production capabilities for the
content context and nuances of the seven
platforms that have all the attention
with an overlay of deep empathy for the
person that's consuming it like the one
craft that I've developed and and now
have scaled internally is just human IP
of understanding math and art quant and
qual around you know xx when you look
back at how I'm talking here it's it's
it's value post production contextual
creative it's not posting on LinkedIn
for the sake of posting you know the ROI
of any execution is predicated in your
skill set and so
I arrived at the number based on
eventually at scale AI machine learning
all these things will be able to create
so much micro fragmentation of a lot of
these things and hopefully you know
create content at scale but for the time
being what does you know I for example I
have a 30 person full-time team that
works on my personal content as one
person I did put out 15 pieces of
meaningful post produced creative for
LinkedIn yesterday me you can imagine if
I'm able to do that what I think you
should be able to do me versus Erickson
so as far as failing it's interesting I
don't have like a fantastic obvious
failure and that's actually a weakness
because it's very grounded in my deep
deep deep immigrant roots I've never
done anything that is so overextended
myself that if it didn't work that I
would really fail where I've really
failed is on the things that I haven't
done
I've fantastically passed on uber twice
in the angel round and that $25,000
check would have maybe five hundred
million dollars
I fantastically didn't even reply to air
bed-and-breakfasts email to have which
is what BMB stands for to invest in
their company I've passed on a lot of
opportunities that have become fantastic
they're the most obvious and then and
then the really biggest mistakes I've
made is when I didn't come to a
conference like brilliant minds over the
last five or six years and that would
have been the conference when I met
someone and she and I would have done
something so it's much more when you're
crippled by opportunity it's the hidden
things that you've passed on that are
the great mistakes of your career
especially when you're like me who's not
ever playing a financial arbitrage
machine game where you're trying to
slide one past the goalie and hope your
timings right I'm a marathon runner in a
sprinters costume and so I I don't put
myself in a position to be that bone
the other thing is in my from from 18 to
29 I worked every single day all of them
and so I definitely think like one
vacation a year for a week with my
friends from high school college would
have been a good idea so I was just so
passionate I so wanted to pay my parents
back for being the greatest parents and
bringing me to America that I was
obsessed with building that family
business and I probably could have had a
little bit more leisure in my 20s which
I regret not really but yes you know not
really not because I became successful
honestly because I just loved it like my
you know I go garage sailing on the
weekends literally go to people's yards
and try to buy things for a dollar that
they're selling that was in their
basement and then think and then repost
it on eBay for $8.00 and in that seven
dollar ROI get more excited than landing
an eight million dollar client so for me
businesses my hobby it's a you know and
so that's why I say not really because I
just loved it I loved you know working
the register on a Saturday when I was 25
years old because I loved it
today yes yes
the question is in an ambition of
thousands of pieces of content a day how
do I also nail home relevance which is a
big part of it so ironically this volume
framework inevitably creates relevance
what will happen it's kind of like a
workout plan if I'm able to get my
partner's friends people I care about
clients my own stuff into a framework of
volume inevitably let's just say
somebody was in here and said approved
and everyone's like okay now we do it
inevitably tomorrow's board meeting is
well what are we gonna say and what you
realize is and this is devastating like
one of the things that's been really
fascinating and we work with very large
companies is once you see it you can't
unsee it and and the level of visceral
negative energy I have towards the
modern-day marketing world watching some
of my clients starting the process of
going there it's real fun for me because
literally a week earlier they're having
this subjective completely non practical
meeting and then a month later after the
first month of this work they can't even
stay in the room for ten minutes because
it seems so silly
it's like many things in life once you
see something sometimes you can't unsee
it so the entire model is built on
relevance all of a sudden you are making
a piece of content to female CIOs in
Russia because you're making 5,000
pieces of content like you're not gonna
make vanilla anymore you're in the
business of selling vanilla you are
everything is so over corporatized and
everything's trying to reach everybody
it even when the seed of the idea was a
good idea by the time it sees the day of
life it's vanilla when you've made the
commitment to producing volume
everything is relevant because you start
becoming educated on how deeply powerful
these platform
and if I want to reach a CTO that went
to MIT and I want to use MIT colors in
the creative because I know that makes
her or him more likely to click it I
mean this is real stuff now all of a
sudden 5,000 you can't imagine how
quickly through a detailed conversation
around this 5,000 seems way too little
everything like just think about the two
examples I gave you and how your minds
running with the fact that this is
actually in perpetuity every school
every neighborhood every geographic
every job title every organization like
that's just the framework of seven or
eight cohort beginnings that is an x and
y which allows you to go forever you
could be making content that starts with
hey are you 28 years old and the person
sees it is yeah I am
you know like you can't imagine how
infinite this actually plays out and so
you know it was fun to hear you ask the
question because I was smiling inside
I'm like it's it's once you make the
commitment to that framework the only
thing you can do is relevance and by the
way relevance is the only thing that
sells not potential reach which is the
currency of big companies GRPs
and impressions and the cost of those
impressions potential reach not actual
reach it's being reported as you reach
those people you don't believe that you
don't believe that article reached 29
million people potential reach versus
actualized relevant consumption that is
the Delta hey sir please
a party group of 500 operators key
decision-makers in each operator yes
when we do focused on key launches they
are very interested to read them
whenever we started going more into
volume yes yes yes you know it's it's
still interesting our volumes of viewers
promo but it's also young students it's
a row tank interested people general so
yeah yes so don't don't let them see it
the question is we're flooding the 500
decision-makers who actually drive our
business if we go to the smile model yes
we build the macro brand and there's
more interest but we're actually over
communicating to the decision maker
which makes them tune us out which could
be detrimental to our business don't let
them see it see the thing that's most
fun about being an actual practitioner
of your craft which I'm sure all of you
feel the same you know it's funny over
the last five to seven years I'm like
wait a minute I really understand this I
really understand wine and I really
understand the New York Jets what I
don't understand is everything else so
I've started becoming a very not
interesting dinner guest because I don't
even have excitement anymore to talk
about things that I'm a headline reader
of or kind of know you could black out
the 500 people that you're scared of
bothering when you're posting that
content you're also making assumptions
that they see everything there's so many
variables that go into this plus we
haven't had the conversation of what you
should be surrounding you know what's
great about b2b you know who you're
selling to you know a lot of might be to
be friends get mad at me but I've done
very well in exiting my SAS businesses I
have a b2b
this now I used to have a b2c business
b2b is easier than b2c I'm just don't
know what else to say
one man's point of view I just like the
idea of knowing who the 500 people are
that I need to do business with let's go
into a slight variation of my model in
what you and I are discussing a on our
LinkedIn channel let's start there our
ability to not let them see it is very
high you just black them out from those
posts so that's mission one biggest
issue that we were talking about in the
short term accomplished but let's go in
on an offense instead of defense what
about the fact that we can know that
those 500 people in today's world based
on how many people are sharing or if we
want to just take the admin of that
person out for a drink if they're into
fishing if they're into proper football
if they're into many other things and
then we can feed them that I literally
closed the four million dollar account
by talking to that person about st.
Louis Cardinals baseball because I saw
that that's what he was tweeting about
the reason we take them on fishing trips
and golf trips and all the stuff that we
wine and dine on we could be doing in
relevant content for a hundredth of the
price so that's my answer to that
question right we don't have to flood
them because that's what's good about
modern technology you can control the
levers more importantly I'd like to
flood them with more things that all
individual five and we should have one
person we should have five people in
creative you know in a world where
you're like we have a small team and we
have to do everything and dumb [ __ ] like
press releases I'm saying let's create
eight person production and strategy and
media teams per 500 people I would build
a four thousand person team to produce
content for five hundred people because
it would be ROI positive to your point
they're driving our business so let's
become the greatest executor of what
they want to consume and brings them
value the problem is not knowing what
you're putting out the problem is is
that oftentimes we're not putting out
content that is valuable to the person
on the other side in the macro
we're talking about our products and
services Ericsson has permission to talk
about everything and what Ericsson needs
to do is make a graph of what are the
other ninety things that these 500
people care about that have nothing to
do with us and let's be the greatest
publisher of information around that not
to mention the ability to use these
channels to create content that pulls
those people into real life is
remarkable I use digital as a gateway
drug to interpersonal relationships so
if we know that 13 of them are the
biggest wine connoisseurs and we decide
to get Jancis Robinson and fly her in
here and do a wine night and then send
an invitation on LinkedIn that is gated
that are you interested in a 1961
Bordeaux tasting hosted by Jancis
Robinson on a pretty boat on a beautiful
summer day here in in xyc City tends to
work we're just not committed to the
craft because we are used to a Bock
top-down culture of communications make
a single blunt object at the top force
it down every channel with no context oh
hi how are you yep heard yes thank you
yes yes yes yes yes sure the question is
thank you for knowing a little bit about
kind of my trajectory of how I've been
filling the pipes what I've been to your
point and thank you for knowing that
what I was definitely when I
transitioned from wine - let's say
entrepreneurship in my content it was
two thousand seven eight nine and we
were going through a global economic
crisis and as you can imagine as an
immigrant who answered your question of
what my regret is I don't I think it's
very difficult to give advice that says
become more talented be born with more
talent very not practical so where I
found myself was going to another place
that felt very practical to me and as
you can imagine it's all I ever saw for
the first 35 years of my life which was
work ethic was a controllable part of
the game that if you did that if you're
out working your competition practicing
after practice all the things we know
about sports and music and theater and
acting and other things that that was an
incredible advantage and in a time and
place where people were getting laid off
and things of that nature it hit the
right tone it was natural to me and the
timing was right to the more nuanced
question which I appreciate which means
you're paying attention over the last 18
to 24 months as the world changes
as we get into entitlement era after 15
years of economic or 10 years of great
global economic growth much like my
concern with entrepreneurship because
there's so much money in the system
everybody's idea gets funded and we're
not building businesses we're just
building companies to get more funding
what has also happened is a more human
conversation more nordic and european
centric than us and china centric about
work-life balance about mental health
issues about burnout
I found myself two years ago watching
contemporaries even friends start to use
me as a poster child of bad that I was
pushing too much burnout and things of
that nature
hustle porn and other things and I was
empathetic to it as much as I was hurt
and wanted to make 500 videos of in the
first book which is my Bible I talked
about if you want to work 9:00 to 5:00
and make 40,000 a year but you're happy
you've won I think I've been and I have
been incredibly consistent around
happiness not money and many other
things but to your point because of my
personality traits what was associated
was hustle and things that nature so I
have to take responsibility for that and
so over the last 24 months I have spent
more time and energy to contextualize
everything to make sure I'm covering the
basis so that people know where I stand
on this which is what I said earlier I
don't really regret it because I loved
business is my hobby but if one wants to
go to every softball game or every track
meet or you know work 31 hours a week
and they're fulfilled that makes me
happy I don't get to judge so yes I
think what's so great about
communication and so great about
advancements is you can create clarity
you can talk about different things I
talk a lot more about parenting today
than I did in the past because not even
because I'm a parent because I've been
more in tune to how I was parented so
yes I've definitely been more aggressive
in making sure the things that I've
always believed are more associated with
me because I have no interest in other
people painting a picture about me that
isn't true
but it all goes to one big game of
self-awareness you know you can get
burned out work in 30 hours a week
because you're unhappy because you're
trying to be to work life but what
actually you are is an alpha go-getter
and you do want to grind not living your
actual life is the problem letting other
people's opinions dictate your behavior
is the problem self-confidence most
parents create insecurities hi that
works out
whoever has the mic gets asked a
question sure yes first of all thank you
the question is how do you practically
make five thousand so a couple things
one as I became more in tune to this
model over the last three years which is
the evolution of everything I've been
doing it's really interesting twitter
has become a far more important platform
for me and Linkedin has become a far
more powerful platform because five
thousand when you hear that seems super
daunting if you're close enough to the
business where Ericsson does the cliche
thing which it spends five hundred
thousand dollars making a video because
their creative agency wanted to make it
and nobody's ever gonna say it and it
cost five hundred thousand because you
starred somebody in it and it's just
five hundred thousand and so you hear
that and you're like this is crazy we
can't make five thousand it took us four
and a half months to make that one video
when you think about the world the way I
do which is you have so much internal IP
that putting out fifty tweets in the
morning in written form with no picture
video support behind it but they are
just thoughtful questions statements
observations hot takes as I like to call
them whatever it may be when you do that
all of a sudden
you start seeing how the number can go
up but where it gets most interesting is
why do you do that
why should Erickson from 9:00 a.m. to
11:00 a.m. put out you know 84 between
LinkedIn and Twitter because that's a
place where you can get away with the
volume in the feed without overexposure
but can still get actual consumption
because if it doesn't do well it doesn't
penalize you in the same way the way an
Instagram or Facebook does this goes
into understanding the platforms why
should LinkedIn excuse me Ericsson put
out 84 pieces of content in written form
on LinkedIn and Twitter from 9:00 a.m.
to 11:00 a.m. every morning it's because
what happens from 11:00 a.m. to 4:00 in
the afternoon next what is amazing about
the volume model is the notion of
marketing for the sake of better
marketing so what happens after you post
those 78 is you start getting quant and
qual feedback and what you do with that
feedback is you make the next decision
which is are you going to write more
about that or has there been such a huge
reaction to people's response on what 5g
actually means to their day to day not
just faster and better battery but how
our entire world changes when you create
that speed of information how that
actually makes autonomous cars real how
that actually allows a doctor in Peru to
perform a surgery on somebody in New
York how that actually actually actually
does when you see the response now all
of a sudden you say you know what that
little three sentences we said about did
you know when 5g is in your life this
happens got such a big response why
don't we now have our graphic designer
make an infographic real quick around
five things you don't know about 5g and
let's post that at 3:37 p.m. today and
then when that goes well then you decide
why don't we go quick little video on
our iPhone talking to Lars in R&D he
knows a lot about this [ __ ] let's go
over to him large says it and then you
just post it not with what's quality
with green-screen and lighting I mean
I was powdered before I came out here
right now that to me is not the variable
of success of this talk that was not
going to be the variable that made this
go well or not it was what I was gonna
say and Lars with an iPhone with bad
lighting saying something thoughtful and
then that posted at 7:04 p.m. on our
twitter to the small group that cares
matters and so when you get into that
mindset you can see how it works and its
really just having writers designers
something we call predators predators
which are people who can film and post
produce for the channel all in one
person talent humans commitment to being
able to pay those people to do the thing
because you value that more than the
lighting in your booth in Spain at a
conference I went there I you know it's
always fun to go somewhere where the
group knows exactly where you're going
and and I'll tell you why I go there I
go there because you're going there to
check a box of what's normally gonna
happen anyway your your most senior
executives are having dinners with those
clients to begin with anyway you're just
you're just spending a lot of money on
something that actually matters far less
I don't mind checking a box for
perception is reality I don't I mind
that what I actually said which is the
lighting of that booth or that pavilion
costs more than all the media dollars
you deploy against target is LinkedIn
creative that's what I mind doesn't mean
you're not spending a ton of money on
media it's just that your media partner
is incentivized to spend that media in a
way that's in their vested interests not
yours this is the conversation this is
real life I like real life
thank you